gearing up for their return or will
stick with distance learning they can
always use a little extra support
we caught up with the dean for the
college of education with university of
phoenix pam rogerman
she says we as parents need to be in
tune with what's happening with our kids
take an active role in helping them
we've got to check in on their workload
the online portals for the greats to see
how they're doing
regardless of whether it's the little
ones or your high schooler we as parents
need to be consistent
one of the things i think that we
parents really have to really just kind
of
check ourselves is to make sure that we
keep the schedule
at home so that our kids are eating at a
normal time they're
getting their sleep or keeping them off
their phones because
they're gonna be exhausted um especially
if they're going to jump into some
activities i know that
you know some sports are opening up our
teachers have been adjusting their
instruction all year long but as our
students go back
and have that busy day she adds it's
more important than ever if we sense
they're struggling with homework
to keep track of that reach out to the
teacher even for the upper grade saying
you know my child normally gets b's
normally does well in math or so and so
but is now struggling
and ask the teacher what are you seeing
of course keep an eye on their social
and emotional
well-being that's important too